1-click is all it takes data protection
is a big issue a controversial piece of
legislation passenger name record which
covered air travel was struck down last
April because they put all of us and an
umbrella of suspicion but were the world
struggling to stop the so-called Islamic
states of foreign fighters committing
acts of terrorism on EU soil PNR could
be making a comeback essentially we
start from a premise that we never never
use data about individuals for any other
purpose than for the individual
themselves that is an almost impossible
situation but the amount of data that
being collected under PNR is much less
than the data that we're going to be
requiring from people for a whole lot of
other things 2015 a year for Europe to
focus on those most desperately in need
every year Parliament votes to put its
weight behind a single project next
year's focus is already an area where
the EU does well Europe is the world's
biggest a donor so what new life can be
breathed in I'd like us to do more on
women and girls we have the Millennium
Development Goals but we still have a
lot of discrimination against women and
we also have a lot of violence against
women another topic on the development
committees agenda child undernutrition
victims of their circumstance 2.6
million children from the developing
world under the age of five die every
year the EU does spend a lot of money on
this issue but one of the problems is
making sure the aid gets through to
children making sure we have the right
kind of health support and those will be
our top priorities
a blind date with a twist what could he
do if we didn't have the use of your
eyes we all found out we want to show
that the difficulties we facing for
tasks that are taken for granted by
people we can see the difficulty for us
is that since you know these touch
screens have no buttons no dials it's
just impossible for us to eat 22 to
access them those would come to offer
support had this message I think
blindness or impaired vision is one of
the things that people who don't have it
find most scary the European blind Union
pulls it all together for Europe there's
such a lot of help and advice and
support the European blind Union are
calling for new legislation and I've see
the new commission will push through the
changes they need